on dirait presque qu'ils volent c'est le
mouvement que laëtitia guichard m
capturés depuis cinq ans elle qui rêvait
d'être professeur deux ps manie ses deux
passions la photographie et le sport
c'est ce côté spectaculaire
elle est dynamique donc j'essaie
d'allier tout ce qui est urbain au
mouvement sportif c'est des
collaborations face à face moi je j'ai
vite c'est vrai tous les tous les
événements où il ya beaucoup de monde ce
qu'il red bull et c'est parce que il ya
trop de monde et je peut pas produire ce
que je veux mais je préfère des face à
face comme on dit l'exposition retrace
cet amour pour la photo avant le sport
laetitia guichard capture des instants
de la nature paysages et monde animalier
des clichés réalisés lors de voyages je
recherche c'est tout ce qui est à
présent en fait je vais souvent au
coucher de soleil lever de soleil parce
que c'est des moments où pas déjà y'a
pas grand monde sur les plages et sur
les montagnes et parce que la lumière
est vraiment magique et voilà et
j'attends patiemment le matin savoir si
les lumières pour être belle et souvent
je repart bredouille
parce que souvent ces bouchées où ça va
pas mais c'est pas si simple que ça
lever de soleil couché de soleil
[Musique]
il ya toujours sept minutes où le soleil
est vraiment le plus rose possible ou le
plus jeune possible route
voilà on fait plusieurs clichés pour
avoir le meilleur des clichés pris sur
le vif ou retravailler laetitia guichard
cherche avant tout à parler de sa
passion elle expose une vingtaine de ses
oeuvres à voisins le bretonneux
[Musique]